le château des comtes du perche six
mille ans d'histoire qui s'apprête à
sortir des limbes
tour à tour assiégée par les onglets 14
128 ce château a connu les affres de la
guerre de cent ans à la révolution ce
sera même une prison ici la pierre n'est
pas un témoin muet elle raconte
l'histoire sous cet angle vous voyez
toutes les étapes historiques du château
depuis le grand donjon carré qui a été
construit en 1035 un des plus vieux
donjon en pierre d'europe est un des
plus aussi puisqu'il fait trente mètres
de haut c'est le donjon des comptes du
perche là où il habitait et puis le
logis renaissance qui a été construit
par les princes de bourbon et puis le
pavillon que le duc de sully le ministre
d'henri iv a fait construire et donc il
a fait rajouter ce petit édifice de
style louis xiii
à côté les combles du château tête du
début de la renaissance parfaitement
concernés on est dans la charpente qui a
été construite par charles d'anjou le
frère du roi rené
une charpente en carène renversé avec
des arcatures en bois du perche sans
aucun clou uniquement avec des chevilles
et dérivés comme dans la marine à
l'époque et qui a été entièrement
construite en 470 salles au début de la
renaissance
quand la famille de bourbon s'est
installé à nogent agrégé d'histoire
normalien énarque et hommes politiques
harold eu l'arc a hérité de ses grands
parents à document qui fait date
c'est le testament de rachel de coach
filet duchesse de sully la femme du
principal ministre d'henri iv un
document intéressant parce que non
seulement il fait la liste des biens du
duc de sully qui en tant que ministre
des finances avait des propriétés
considérable mais il montre bien aussi
que sa femme qui était percheronne de
naissance n'a eu de cesse toute sa vie
que de faire acquérir des terres dans le
perche chez elle à son mari au fil des
pages
elle liste tous les biens qu'elle
souhaite léguer à son fils et elle
conclut comme souvent dans les
testaments l'ancien régime par une
phrase lapidaire et expéditive pour mes
filles de rang et la marquise de
mirepoix
je les prie de se contenter de ce
qu'elles ont en mariage comme ayant été
largement dotées c'est attendre c'est la
loi d'ancien régime avant la révolution
tout pour les mâles tout pour les
garçons et les filles n'ont que ce
qu'elles ont le jour de leur mariage
le duc de sully et son épouse rachelle
de coach filet ils sont illuminés dont
une chapelle à nogent le rotrou
conformément à ses dernières volontés en
armure avec un manteau de duke son bâton
de maréchal de france dans une attitude
plus que seigneurial et c'est un des
très beaux monuments de la ville de
nogent le rotrou que nous conservons
encore aujourd'hui nous devons la
représentation en marbre blanc du couple
à barthélémy boutin sculpteurs du roi